doc
i can't even lie man
we didn't start off on the best footing
i know you wanted to trade me too i know
you did
i
i mean i was accustomed to doing things
my way didn't like someone coming and
telling me what to do
however when i started to listen to you
and understand your criticism as
coaching
that's when i became great
so thank you also this one i knew you
was a player's coach
you know i remember coming in to shoot
around one time hung over and we had a
game that morning
and we was running a play and you know
the play i was supposed to go through
cut through and so we run the play and i
go to one knee
and he look at me
like paul what you doing
you're like paul come here i'm like oh
man you know i'm kind of covering my
breath i know it's
i know it's banging
so i kind of stopped short he was like
paul
go home and be ready for tonight get
some rest and i was like thanks coach
and i ran out of there i ran out of
there
i'm telling you i had 30 that night we
won i was like
players coach
[Laughter]
[Applause]